paul ronzheimer uns jetzt zugeschaltet
aus der ukraine aus nico paul wie
solltest du dir worte wladimir putins
ist das eine neue eskalationsstufe oder
sind das die typischen propaganda worte
wie wir sie erkennen in diesem krieg
das waren die erwartbaren worte von
wladimir putin ich fand es erstaunlich
dass er ja davor eigentlich gesagt hat
das war schon in ordnung wenn sie das
wollten aber wir als russland machen
dann eben unsere reaktion auf unserer
seite insgesamt wird man darauf schaut
patricia was ja grund auch für den krieg
in der ukraine waren nämlich dass
wladimir putin verhindern will dass die
nato größer und mächtiger wird da hat er
es genau das gegenteil erreicht durch
die tatsache dass eben finnland und
schweden in die nato gehen dass da jetzt
auch alle wege frei sind deswegen hat er
genau das gegenteil von dem erreicht was
er mit dem krieg in der ukraine ende
februar wollte paul auch die klitschko
brüder sind aus der ukraine nach madrid
gereist wir haben es eben gesehen
wirklich jeder große staats und
regierungschefs wollte ein foto mit den
beinen wie wirksam ist der auftritt der
klitschko-brüder dort vor ort beim
nato-gipfel
wahnsinnig wichtig dass auch ukrainische
politiker spitzenpolitiker wie vitali
klitschko dort vor ort sind und ich habe
gestern abend mit beiden telefoniert da
hatten sie gerade joe biden getroffen
und im jahr 15 minuten mit dem us
präsidenten gesprochen und joe biden hat
erzählt dass seine enkelkinder große
fans sind und die klitschko brüder an
also selbst der us-präsident erscheint
fasziniert von dem kampf für die
freiheit der beiden box brüder andere
staatschefs haben mit witzen reagiert
als sie die beiden getroffen haben olaf
scholz hat gefragt ob ich denn hier auch
die echten klitschkos also eine ein
bezug zu den fake debatten um den fake
klitschko dies ja in den vergangenen
tagen ergeben hat als russische komiker
bürgermeister eingelegt haben unter
anderem die berliner bürgermeisterin und
sich als vitali klitschko ausgegeben
haben
also man konnte sich dort von der
echtheit der klitschko brüder dann
überzeugen der beim nato-gipfel paul
noch ein wort zur gegenwärtigen
situation du gerade in mikro dort
gestern abend auch wieder
raketenangriffe dass auch nach zehn
angriffe auf das einkaufszentrum jetzt
im zentral in der zentrale ukraine hast
du den eindruck der krieg verlagert sich
zusehends auf verteilt sich mehr hatte
sich ja in den letzten wochen zunehmend
auf den osten konzentriert
im osten verlief verläuft die direkte
von linie patricia genauso wie in carson
also im süden und in kharkiv aber die
raketenangriffe auf andere städte wie
hier wie auch nie wie clemens schick die
hatte es ja immer gegeben da geht es
russland vor allem darum zu versuchen
hier munitionsdepots zutreffen waffen zu
treffen ölraffinerien zu treffen und
dafür zu sorgen dass ja kein nachschub
mehr an die front kommt und tatsächlich
ist das zunehmend ein problem für die
ukraine ihm fehlt es an munition und das
könnte sich zu einem großen problem aus
marl besten dank paul ronzheimer für uns
ins mikro in der ok danke